[Musica]
come si fa a non mettere mi piace ha un
gioco che parte così bella tutti ragazzi
femmine di questo video sono vari geni
che oggi siamo su la grande avventura di
natale di papirus come cazzo fai a
chiamarti papirus non si parte a bello
quando si avvicinano le vacanze di
natale di due fratelli iniziano i
preparativi per i regali e in papirus
chi cazzo è questo questo questo e
papirus goro ci ha chiesto di seppellire
accese forin aspetta perché non hai
sentito dove vuole il tesoro ora bene di
odio dopo ma se non torna prima di dieci
minuti infransero senza di lui il mio
fratello lurido stronzo vabbè dietro ed
i ragazzi non ho capito bene dove devo
andare
che bello ovunque ea tempo il gioco a
tempo c'è ma di tutti pezzi di merda
novell ha introdotto ragazzi ma è un
racing game cioè e lo capirete tra poco
perché posso anche spinare fantastico
problema è che bellissimo sono spider
man e ragazzi non lo sapevo quindi posso
anche cos'è un checkpoint vedo che sia
un check point ragazzi ma non è quello
il problema il problema il problema è
che l'altro poi li ammazzo la famiglia
il problema ragazzi che ha il suo gioco
ea tempo e bisogna tener conto del tempo
cosa impossibile
c'è una rana ah ok bellissimi altro
veramente posso arrampicarmi sui muri
manco spider man
perché era lì il check point tua sorella
deve morire tuo fratello no perché se
tuo fratello è il check points e timore
fratello c'era un po nel culo minico
però stai attento che so dove abiti l'ho
visto all'inizio
ok per la madonna è la madonna è la
madonna pensavo fosse un reggae in più
tranquillo proprio no te lo dico io a
zio non di skype sachs aveva allora ci
sei arrivato anche più da solo
l'importante quello guarda il gioco
stesso mi prende per il culo fantastico
non ti preoccupare solo una perdita di
pochi secondi sono secondi che potevo
passare meglio tipo a leggere le
istruzioni dei mobili dell'ikea che è
comunque un qualcosa di costruttivo o
dio santo 40 minuti per fra sta cazzo di
parte niente cambio grande secca maio
goddess mia suocera
porca eva ma perchè non fai un salto
norma i ragazzi se finisce il tempo mi
fa ripartire da zero
no perché veramente potrei far scendere
qualche non so conoscete gesù ecco mio
amico gesù potrebbe scendere gesù come
faccio come faccia a faccia parte non me
lo dovete spiegare ok quanta roba quanta
quanta quanta che c'era l'autostrada
pure schifosi
ti giuro che si esca fast app artemide
nudo e non è che sia una bella cosa
perché era il gioco che avevo fatto che
somigliava un sacchi ma questo tipo
qualcuno lo storico io non me lo ricordo
più 10 all alzheimer conviene anche la
rabbia quella degli zombie proprio
mangio cadaveri credo che ci sono cose
dice però non vedo come come si
raggiunge
e non può mai stato saltato l'ostacolo
non sono in più come però non riesco ad
andare avanti ora che è impossibile di
quell'uomo donna piano no non lo zio lo
zio bravo di no a zio stato due ore a
fare un cazzo
dove trovare i giochi che mi fanno altri
stonare la vita adesso non sono contento
perfetto piano piano devi andare piano
fratello
no dai porca più ladra l'argano riporta
la e vai vai vai vai vai vai vava il tuo
cane e fissa sulle tombe del cimitero
dei tuoi genitori morti ma perché non
salti più avanti dai dai
troppo poco tempo due minuti e mezzo
faccio prima uccida tv i parenti
maledizione o si si si si
tra i suoi buried and back to the start
ma che cazzo ad back che c'è un minuto
vai vai vai vai vai come faccio a
tornare indietro come torna indietro
come di qua dai dai dai dai dai un
minuto un minuto veloce cazzo porca
mignot vai non pensare a leggere e
cristo dai dai dai dai dai dai dai che
l'ho già spostato tutto cosa mai
penso che ce la posso fare lo so
bye bye bye bye bye bye lara alle rane
ma dio mio
c'è per caso dove cazzo è lo star dove
dove dai tutta na che mio fratello si
mangia il pranzo da solo verso verso
perso settimana allo zio
se ti mangi la crostata della nonna da
solo
[Musica]
c'è della suspense vado da cribis no
grail b se il mio fast food strom
soltanto e riadottato e non te l'avevo
mai detto succo niente ragazzi è se ma è
andato da solo a mangiare quindi che
devo fare
lo rifaccio una volta seriamente quale
motivo perso sei ore di tempo a
trastullarmi pene per ora guarda la
velocità qua qua quanto veloce adesso
dio mio
fatto sta parte senza morire una volta
basta farne una volta alla fine il suo
gioco per capirlo ok
il problema è che quella volta che te lo
fai che non lo capisci cristoni in sei
lingue ma anche adesso è certo c'è
possibilità mezz'ora buona sopra quella
parte lì che non riesco a fare perfetto
perfetto pure questo ha messo un'ora e
mezza siamo arrivati qua più di 9 minuti
di tempo voglio vedere se non riesco a
fare un cazzo
la parte veramente l'impossibilità fatta
videogioco
grandi abbracci ho sepolto il tesoro si
che che tesoro è poi a il sepolto lo
torta la torta la embolo nyanza beh non
ho capito cosa ha sepolto ragazzi però
spero ne sia valsa la pena per dieci
minuti di gesù cristico livello povera
come triste di farmi saltare no perché
c'è una triste esistenza frate fatelo
dire anche io se continua a morire così
sono arrivato dieci minuti chi cazzo è
c'è un urlo che magistrato sto caduto
giù fantasma barca e va spero che tu
abbia sepolto tua madre prima non il
tesoro tua madre ti deve morire tutta la
stirpe arrivo qui è ok io ti ringrazio
in 40 anni per far ci voleva tanto dai
dai dai dai dai dove vado
ok o ragazzo così fatta st parte
iniziale prima ci ho messo trenta
secondi a farla adesso devo farla o tre
minuti e mezzo
però devo farla all'indietro cosa che
che potrebbe risultare difficile ok ok
no
ho saltato perché ho saltato perché sono
un deficiente perché lo stato perché
sono un deficiente
dai dai su sì sì frate bravissimo
ok ok va dai al contrario impossibile da
avanti dalla data prima allora mi sta
impiccando che cazzo sto dicendo visto
incespicando con le parole di sto
dicendo da davanti all'ara cagata così
mi è impossibile
si no cazzo è arrivato alla fine cioè se
non ci andrai al fast food da solo
fratello di stupido quanto sei nano si
vede che sei adottato un tono devo dire
io si capisce quindi lei sepolto se ce
l'ha fatta bene e dove l'hai sepolto
sono sicuro che qualsiasi umano riuscirà
ad arrivare lì senza problemi per
qualche motivo ne dubito però grazie
mille lo stesso di end che animazioni
che ti colpiscono proprio il cuore cioè
proprio frozen era fatto con le sue
animazioni la stessa qualità visiva se
sono riuscito io a fare un l'inconscio
così in dieci minuti
non esiste che voi non riusciate a fare
le verifiche di matematica in cinque
credo che qualsiasi cosa nel mondo possa
essere fatta in meno di dieci minuti
perché questo era l'impossibile fatto
videogame con ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che le animazioni questa
neve che questa neve bellissima se
questa grafica vi ha colpito nell'anima
ha lasciato mi piace anche a baciare
facebook e come lido trattando
iscrizione io sono stati mutande per
tutto il video ma nessuno se n'è accorto
quindi forte se agazio terroristi
discrete ci vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazza